in the last seven years
uber has gutted the American taxi
industry it's launched a fleet of
self-driving cars in Pittsburgh and it's
become the most valuable startup in
history whatever today
uber is promising flying cars flying
cars the company calls it uber elevate
and it says there within 10 years it
will be running a global network of
on-demand urban electric vehicles that
take off and land vertically ok deep
breath here
uber has no plans to actually build and
certify flying cars it says it's got a
whole pile of technical and regulatory
and infrastructural problems to work
through first and it wants industry
players to come together and work
through all of those challenges together
it can play that catalyst role because
it has access to some 10 million users
many of whom would certainly be onboard
believe it or not building a flying car
isn't even the hard part here uber
expects that fully electric VTOL that's
vertical takeoff and landing will be
ready within five years an aviation
experts say that's a reasonable time
line uber isn't alone here
california-based Joby aviation says that
within 5 years it will have its own
electric VTOL taxi service in operation
and the Pentagon just gave Virginia
based Aurora flight sciences almost 90
million dollars to work on its own VTOL
plane which uses a hybrid electric
system and looks like a big harmonica
chasing a smaller harmonica last year
nasa's battery powered 10 motor greased
lightning made its first flight
so what's keeping you grounded
government the same aviation experts who
say this tech could be ready within five
years also say there is no way the
certification process keeps up with that
pace right now the FAA doesn't even have
rules for certifying electric airplanes
it is not going to be happy about semi
autonomous aircraft to sipping human bro
grammars through SFO s glide path oh and
that whole taking off vertically and
then flying horizontally thing that's
never even been done in a civilian
aircraft let's say one of these
companies a actually makes a working
plane and B somehow gets the FAA to say
it's okay to fly and we'll even say the
FAA and NASA finally implement that
autonomous version of air traffic
control they've been working on forever
so these things don't just smack into
another all the time then how do you get
the service into the towns and cities
where people can actually use it well
that's the part over is actually pretty
good at it could do the same thing here
it's already done with cars meaning
connecting passengers with pilots
advising them on routes and collecting
its share of the fare
putting aside the company's dubious
track record of working with governments
uber elevate really isn't as crazy as it
sounds and yes I know every technology
reporter has cracked on these rocks
before but guys we might actually
beginning flying cars